How can we expand upon the lore of The
Nutcracker? We need to have - well,
how about there's another realm?
There's like, two realms, like -
No, not enough realms!
There's at least three realms!
Shut up, Steve! Four realms! Four!
Take the realms to the max! Yeah.
Tom, can you tell us about a Disney live-action
failure that people probably forgot about?
I got two, and whether they forgot about them or
not probably has a lot to do with how old they
are, or whether or not they've suffered a head
injury. The first one, the big one ... it was the
result of this magical time about 10 years ago,
before Disney had movies for boys and they wanted
them. They wanted boy movies something fierce,
but they didn't have Star Wars yet, and they
didn't have superheroes yet, so they basically
had to come up with their own solution. Yeah.
So instead, what they decided, and
what all little boys love - I think
you'll agree - is adaptations of Edgar
Rice Burroughs novels from around 1913.
Sure.
So Disney made this movie called several
things, called John Carter of Mars initially,
and then they made an animated movie
that failed pretty spectacularly
called Mars Needs Moms. And they were like,
"well, I guess people just don't like movies
with Mars in the title," so they
changed the name to John Carter.
Was that a Disney movie?
Yeah, yeah. Actually, another one of the
biggest box office disappointments
of all time. As 21st century stories
with a Confederate captain as the protagonist
go, it's pretty good. It's pretty good.
Yikes.
There were a lot of things that people pointed
to as the reason the movie didn't work. On paper,
it probably should have. It was being directed
by the guy who made WALL-E and Finding Nemo.
It had a pretty good script, a huge budget, it
was pretty beautifully shot. It did star not one
but two of the characters from X-Men Origins:
Wolverine, which might have been short-sighted.
Taylor Kitsch.
Taylor Kitsch, who, I had a buddy
a couple years back who did a
perfect Taylor Kitsch impression
like, in any role that he does.
I can't imagine what that would be.
Was it just a guy talking? I don't understand
how you do a perfect Taylor Kitsch impression?
It's just this. He just-
Ah, yeah.
That's it.
That's definitely a Tim Riggins face.
And if you do that through the whole movie, yeah.
Anyway, the movie ate it really hard. It was
- depends on who you ask, it was somewhere
in the range of $250 to $300 million to make
this movie, with like an extra $100 million
that went into advertising it. Flopped
terribly. Nobody saw it. It was a huge bummer.
I saw it. I saw it in theaters.
I did too, yeah. I thought it was fun.
It was ... fine. I think I came out
of it saying, "that was okay I guess."
That was my reaction. I
was just like, "all right."
It was acceptable.
I don't remember - I'm sure I had specific
criticisms at the time, but it was
a long time ago so I don't remember.
It's been a while. This was 2012. You
would have been ... 49 at the time?
I had just turned 49 in 2012. Back
when my memory was good. Not like now.
I don't remember those days.
I can't imagine.
So that was a huge drag. And then a year
later, they had another one, another
movie that was kind of in the same vein, which was
The Lone Ranger. It was Gore Verbinski's follow up
to the Pirates of the Caribbean movies. It was
very much a matter of - the Pirates movies just
turned into the biggest franchise in the world,
so maybe if we just do the same thing again-
Literally the same thing by
throwing Johnny Depp back into it.
But this time they put on a bird on his head.
True.
This time they put a bird on his head.
An important distinction.
Like a Portlandia sketch.
It's very much like that, yeah.
Just put a bird on it, yeah.
Put a bird on it!
Oh boy.
Doesn't always work. And starring Armie Hammer.
Armie Hammer-
Before we all knew that dude was a mess!
That guy-
In a way, it's really good that this movie tanked
because otherwise Disney might be stuck with a big
franchise with a star who, well, let's
just say less than employable right now.
Yep.
Without going into the details right now.
Let's not.
I mean, that depends entirely on
several things. Fascinatingly,
the villain in the movie - I don't know if
either of you saw it - is a cannibal. Just,
an extra layer of difficult
to watch that gets added-
Stop it.
Into The Lone Ranger. It's like, two and a
half hours long. It's beautifully shot, it's a
gorgeous movie, but impossible to get through.
Really, really boring. But like, Hans Zimmer did
the score, it's beautiful. The landscapes that
they shot are just incredible. I don't know.
Everything about it from a cinematic perspective,
just beautiful. But it's about an hour too long,
and we were just entering the phase of Hollywood
history where Johnny Depp was no longer fun.
Right.
It's what historians refer to
as "the Great Deppression."
Was this about the time that he started
pulling a Brando and refusing to learn
his lines and he had to reportedly
wear an earpiece and be fed them?
This was exactly around that time. That's why
he had wild hair dangling according to legend.
Those are my picks. Both remarkable in their
own right, both immense failures. Luckily,
they both also came out around the same time
that The Avengers did, so everything
was going to be okay for Disney.
Disney did just fine by the end of that.
Don't worry guys, Disney will be okay. Somehow-
Star Wars, I think, later the same year.
My pick is in a similar
vein, where when you mention
Disney trying to get movies for boys. It
was The Sorcerer's Apprentice starring
Nic Cage and Jay Baruschel, I
think that's how you say his name.
I believe so. I wonder where that guy is.
He's right behind you.
There he is.
I watched this movie thinking "how bad can
this be? It's probably fine." It's so boring.
It's not even fun bad. It's just boring, like,
you're just like "oh my god, is it done?"
One reason in particular I was interested
in watching this movie is because
they filmed a very small, as it turned
out, portion of it in the studio of WFMU,
which is my favorite radio station of all time.
They're a New Jersey-based freeform radio station,
the country's oldest radio station. If you
haven't checked out WFMU, check them out.
What's radio?
Today's episode brought to you by -
No, but there's a scene that takes
place inside a radio station, like,
I think the college radio station. I was
hoping I would get to see more of FMU,
and it was just like three seconds. I was like,
"I'm going to watch this whole thing for that?"
So this explains Brian's vendetta
against Sorcerer's Apprentice,
is he thinks the radio station should
have been featured more prominently!
He went into it wanting to watch a documentary
about a radio station and he's like-
Oh, it's Nic Cage and sorcery!
It's magic and explosions, and it sucks!
They eventually did release a documentary about
the radio station. It's very good.
It's called Sex and Broadcast. Anyway-
Is it better than Sorcerer's Apprentice?
It wouldn't take much, but yes-
Is Nic Cage in it?
It's much better. So no, okay,
but here's the other thing,
right? Here's the other thing about this movie.
It starts - so Jay Baruschel's character, Dave-
Very magical name, yeah.
Yeah, Dave. Dave the sorcerer. He's
a student at like, NYU or something,
and he's a science guy. He's into science, he does
science. And Nicolas cage shows up and he's like,
"I'm a sorcerer, you're a sorcerer, you might be
the true Merlinian" or whatever it is. And at one
point he says like, Dave asks, "so sorcery - is
it science? Is it magic?" And Nicolas Cage goes,
"yes" because he's trying to say it's
both, it's science and it's magic,
and so once you realize that you can
become a true sorcerer. Okay, whatever.
So the whole like, the whole
magic powers are based on,
like, I guess believing in yourself really good.
That's like, that's it. That's the whole thing.
And for the long, for the whole period, the whole
movie, he can't figure out, he can't do it. He
sucks at magic, he can't do magic. You suck,
you suck, you suck. It's no good - I guess,
because he doesn't believe in himself well enough.
And I'm thinking this whole time, "he's
a science guy. He's going to beat the bad
guy at the end using science." He's going
to use science. He's going to show that he
doesn't need magic to win the day because
if you believe in yourself - with science -
or whatever, you know like, use
what you know. Use your knowledge.
If you believe in yourself with
science, then use what you know.
Yeah, that's your real power.
His real power is science. So it's set up in
the beginning, he knows science. At the end,
he should use science. And at the end it's just
like, "oh no, you can just do magic now." So like,
there's this part where he's doing this, like the
hadouken from Street Fighter. You know, he's like,
and he's like, holding back this big fireball
that Alfred Molina is sending at him. Or no,
it's some lady. It's a magic lady. I think
it's Morgan Le Fay. The whole movie sucks.
It's not good. It ends with him just like,
"I am magic after all!" And I'm like,
"no! You start with science, end with like, that's
your setup, there's your payoff, it's not hard."
It's the Willow problem all over again, like
I mentioned a couple of times ago where you
start off with the disappearing pig trick, you end
with the disappearing pig trick. It's a great way-
A setup, a payoff.
Yeah. You set up, you pay off.
So Chekhov's science did not
make a reappearance in this film?
I really like the lesson that magic was the real
magic all along! I think that that's beautiful.
Yeah, exactly!
Yeah, screw science! it's magic!
It was so lame. So yeah, I'm sure
that it's like, if you put it on
it'll probably entertain you enough. It's probably
not the worst movie ever. But it's just overall,
it's disappointing. And it's not like the recipe
isn't there. Like, who wouldn't want to watch a
franchise of live-action sorcerer movies starring
Nicolas Cage as a weird, scraggly, magical hobo?
That sounds very appealing to me.
So yeah, missed opportunity there.
Agree.
So that was my pick. Nina, what did you pick?
So it's tough, because you guys have outlined some
pretty clunky, stinker movies. And I don't think
my pick is necessarily a bad movie, and I think
that it deserves an A for effort, but it was a
certifiable box office bomb for Disney, and I'm
talking about the 2018 adaptation of Madeleine
L'Engle's A Wrinkle in Time, which - I have a
friend who likes the expression "two plus two
equals fish" to explain when something should
absolutely work and it somehow just doesn't.
And this is a great example of two plus two equals
fish, because you have Ava DuVernay - a brilliant
filmmaker who directed Selma, a great documentary
called 13th - and she pivots this story to be
about a young Black girl who is bullied at
school and looking for her astrophysicist father.
The character Meg Murray is never given a racial
identity in the book, so it's a great opportunity
to be a more inclusive story for people. She
cast people like Oprah and Mindy Kaling and Reese
Witherspoon and just ... Gugu Mbatha-Raw, who was
just in Loki. A litany of very, very good actors.
And it just ... this should have worked.
And I remember being very excited to see it,
and being like, "oh. That was
okay." It's not a bad movie,
but it's not as good as it could have
been. The CGI definitely could have
used some work. It's weird to me that in
2018, the CGI managed to be so clunky.
Just, I mean, as a refresher, A Wrinkle
in Time is about a young girl. I believe
she's 13 years old. Also has one of
the best opening lines in literature:
"It was a dark and stormy night."
Great opening. So Meg Murray-
Yeah, I used to love that book when I was a kid.
Yeah, I read the entire-
I was so excited when I saw
that the movie was coming out.
I read the entire series-
And then I don't think I
even heard that it came out.
Right. I read the whole series, I was
hoping this would get spun off into
all of the sequels because the sequels
get real with it and they're a delight.
Is the first sequel called
like, "A Crinkle in Time?"
You bet it is, Brian.
I actually don't even remember
the names of the sequels,
to be honest with you. I last
read them when I was what-
One of them is about a birthday
called "A Sprinkle in Time."
"A Crinkle in Mime."
Oh boy.
I don't know.
Brian, buddy-
Worst. Worst.
It's been a long day.
So Meg Murray is very smart,
she's feeling isolated in school,
she's having kind of a tough time. And she's
also dealing with the fact that her father,
who's a famous astrophysicist, has
just vanished. And these three like,
alien astrological beings, and they are
Mrs. Which, Mrs. Whatsit, and Mrs. Who,
played in that order by Oprah, Reese Witherspoon
and Mindy Kaling, appear to her and they basically
bring her across the astral plane to help try to
track down her dad, because he was ... sucked into
a vortex, I don't know. It's been a long time.
And the movie did not make that any clearer to me.
But yeah, I mean, this should have been
a great re-introduction of a classic
children's book to a whole new audience,
and it should have spawned, I think,
I believe it's three books that followed A
Wrinkle in Time, should have spawned a franchise.
And it cost - let me see, I've got the numbers
right here - it cost about $130 million to make, and it
made about $130 - or no, I'm sorry. $250
million, including marketing and production,
to make, and it only made like $130
million. So pretty bad loss for Disney.
Bummer.
The reviews were mixed too, so it's not like it
was really beloved but people just didn't go to
see it. It was not ... it was an unqualified
not-success, pretty much across the board.
A qualified un-successful -
If only there was a word for such a thing.
That's why they pay me the big
bucks to write and edit, guys.
That's why. But yeah, it should have been
really good, and I'm still kind of bummed that
it just didn't come together, that two plus two
somehow equaled fish in this equation. I hate it.
I'm still curious to check it out, and you know, I
probably will eventually, but one movie that's on
our list of Disney's biggest live action failures
on Looper.com that I am - it's one of those things
that, it's like the Stone Protectors for me, where
I see it and I go "oh, I know exactly what you did
here and I want to see this because it looks so
dumb," is The Nutcracker and the Four Realms.
Oh yeah.
When the trailer for that came out, I
got so excited because I was like, "oh,
this is just one of those terrible ideas
that made it all the way to the theater."
I have never understood why they
keep trying to make movies out of the
freaking Nutcracker. It is
the worst source material.
So the Nutcracker is a delightful-
It's a ballet!
A delightful ballet that takes place
at Christmas, and they're like,
"what if we take this ballet for Christmas
and stuff it full of The Lord of the Rings?"
What if we take a silent ballet and we
make it into magic? It's so confusing.
It just looks completely insane to me. Like,
when the trailer came out I was like, "oh no!"
And I haven't, I haven't dived
into it yet because obviously-
You know what The Nutcracker needs? More
action scenes. That's what that ballet needs.
More action scenes! How can we expand
upon the lore of The Nutcracker? We need
to have - how about there's another
realm! There's like, two realms!
No, not enough realms!
There's at least three realms!
"Shut up, Steve! Four realms! Four!"
Take the realms to the max!
What are the four realms? I don't
know how many realms there are.
I used to be into The Nutcracker when I was a kid,
and I guarantee you, it never crossed my mind
as a child - for whom this movie is meant for
- to be like, "what if there was more stuff?"
I want to know what the four realms
are. What are - is it like, candy? Nuts?
I don't know, that's not
part of the original canon,
Brian. They didn't teach us
that with the ballet moves.
It's just all the corners of the Candyland map.
Okay, wait, I'm looking on Wikipedia.
The four realms, are they like - i'm trying to
think of a good joke and nothing is
coming into my brain. What are they?
The land of sweets.
Sure, Candyland.
The land of snowflakes, the land of flowers.
I was going to ask if it was flowers, yeah.
And the land of amusements.
How is amusements not all of
the other things combined?
Candy is not amusing.
Are the realms at war?
Also-
I don't know.
What are the realms doing
that is of such concern to us?
It's just-
Tom, you have a question.
Go ahead, Tom.
Yeah, well and also - what happens
if they wipe each other out? Like,
if the Realm of Sweets and the
Realm of Flowers go to war,
and they kill all of each other, like,
how does my life change the next day?
I mean, I will say it's admirable-
Are there just no more sweets and no more-
It's admirable to take a ballet where the
plot is the girl gets a magic nutcracker
and then all the mice in her home
become giant and try to murder her,
and then she takes off in a flying sled with
the nutcracker who becomes a real boy who
is a prince and watches flowers and candy
and things dance around for her amusement.
To try and make that even weirder is quite a feat,
and so hats off to the director of this film.
It's just one of those things where I feel like,
if you were at home and you're like, brainstorming
an idea for your next YA novel that you're going
to put up on - or whatever, you're like, "oh, what
if we take this public domain idea and we make
this whole Wizard of Oz type thing?" You're like,
okay, that's fun. That's cool. You can get some
like, a decent book out of it maybe. But that's
clearly not what we're looking at with this movie.
This is a film that someone cooked up. They're
like, "uh, Nutcracker doesn't cost anything
to use. That's a free IP. Let's use that."
See, that's the part that
I think you nailed, yeah.
You've got Keira Knightley, she
wants to do something. Dress her
up like a fairy? I don't know. Four
Realms. Morgan Freeman. Get him,
book him, give him an eye patch. Right.
Doesn't he have an eye patch in this?
I don't know, I haven't seen it.
Nobody knows, Brian. Nobody saw the movie.
It's one of those ideas that, when you see it
- again, like I said about Stone Protectors,
you can just see the cocaine on the boardroom
table. They're just like, everyone's just like,
"this is going to be great! We're
going to be so rich! Let's do it!"
And the fact that this made it through
several different gatekeepers at a production
company - everyone involved was like, "great
idea. Let's do it. Let's do it!" That's crazy.
They're planning out the sequel, the Fifth
Realm, you know? The Nut Uniter? I don't know.
What if realms, but five?
Nut Uniters was going to be the Disney Plus
Saturday Morning cartoon show. There's a
squad of guys who put nuts back together.
Thanks for watching. Don't forget
to hit like and subscribe so you
don't miss a single episode. Thanks
for watching. We love you, goodbye!